The death of a great hero is just the start
of the tragic turns in "Black Panther: Wakanda
Forever."
If the movie left you crying, here's what
you might've missed in the explosive final
act.
Shuri goes through many challenges as she
takes center stage in this sequel.
First she mourns her brother, but after Namor
and his people, the Talokans, attack Wakanda
and cause the drowning death of Ramonda, the
Wakandan royal has even more to mourn.
But let's take a step back before we get to
the third act.
Early on in the movie, Shuri convinces the
Talokans who confront her, Okoye , and Riri
Williams on the bridge in Boston to take her
with them to their hidden ocean empire.
While she's there, she bonds with Namor and
hears the story of how his people came to
live underwater.
Namor also gives her a gift: a piece of jewelry
that once belonged to his mother and is made
with the leaves of the plant that granted
the Talokans the ability to escape the colonists
in Mexico that were taking their land.
"My mother told stories about a place like
this.
A protected land with people that never have
to leave."
There are many parallels between Wakanda and
Talokan, one being that they're the only two
places on Earth that seem to have vibranium.
When a plant plays a key role in giving the
Talokans the power to abandon the land for
the ocean, many viewers may suspect that there's
a high likelihood it may be similar to the
heart-shaped herb that Wakanda relied on to
create the Black Panther.
This turns out to be true.
While it takes Shuri a bit longer to put those
pieces together than it might take the audience,
she eventually discovers that she only has
to shift a few molecules around in order to
use the Talokans' plant to bring the heart-shaped
herb back to life.
After Shuri successfully fabricates the heart-shaped
herb in her lab, it's time to test whether
or not it's the real deal.
While there is no time to do the traditional
ritual associated with becoming the Black
Panther, Shuri successfully goes through the
fundamentals of the process in her lab with
the help of Riri and Nakia.
It's debatable whether Shuri is the best option
for the Black Panther role, considering everything
else on the young royal's plate.
But Nakia doesn't debate Shuri's choice to
take up the mantle or suggest anyone else
would be more suited for the role – at least,
not right away.
Earlier in "Wakanda Forever," Shuri made it
clear that she does not believe in many elements
of the spiritual or ritualistic beliefs that
many Wakandans ascribe to – including the
existence of the ancestral plane.
Despite her insistence that she only believes
in science, there is still a small part of
her that hopes to see her family again in
that mystical realm.
But when Shuri takes the heart-shaped herb
and wakes up there, it's Killmonger who turns
up to greet her.
Shuri is just as shocked as the audience is
to see him.
While Shuri may be unhappy to hear it, Killmonger
suggests to her that out of all the members
of Wakanda's royal family, she is the one
who's the most like him.
"I want the throne."
Killmonger's observations imply that Shuri
is becoming obsessed with vengeance, just
like Killmonger was when he was alive.
But at the time they have their talk, Shuri
doesn't see that to be true.
Ironically, her next move after denying she's
driven by vengeance is to go to M'Baku and
tell him all about her plan for vengeance.
M'Baku initially seems hesitant to go along
with it, but eventually, he and Shuri agree
to join forces and take on the Talokans.
Namor and the Talokans initially revealed
themselves because the whole world is looking
for vibranium in the ocean, and they're getting
close to finding it in the Talokans' hidden
city.
The Talokans had successfully kept their home
hidden for hundreds of years, and by any means
necessary, they'd like to keep it that way.
They also harbor anger at T'Challa for revealing
Wakanda and its vibranium to the world, which
set off a global race to find more of the
substance.
As the only location besides Wakanda with
vibranium, Talokan could become a target for
exploitation.
With the stakes high for the Talokans, the
Wakandans are banking on a vibranium detection
device they installed in the Atlantic Ocean
getting their attention and baiting them out
for a fight.
The Wakandans wait on the surface of the water,
wondering if the Talokans will emerge – and
they don't have to wonder for long.
The Talokans soon erupt out of the water,
and when they find the Wakandans on the ship
poised to attack, it leads to a brutal battle
between the once-secret nations.
As the Talokans and Wakandans fight on the
ship, Riri Williams patrols the air in her
Iron Man armor, working to lure Namor to Shuri
for a one-on-one confrontation.
Riri and Shuri's gambit to capture Namor is
successful, and Shuri traps Namor under a
device she has set up in her ship that seems
to work pretty much like a really big hair
dryer.
Namor has already demonstrated great power
as a fighter with land, air, and sea capabilities,
with mutations that enable him to be remarkably
adept at swimming, fighting, and flying.
But his power seems to rely on the presence
of water, so the Wakandans reason that if
he's sufficiently dehydrated, he'll be significantly
weakened, which will make him much easier
to fight.
On paper, dehydration sounds like an absurd
weakness for a superhero.
When you think about it, it's kind of a weakness
for everybody.
But despite how silly it may sound, the movie
treats this scene — and Namor's valiant
attempts to fight against Shuri's big dehydrator
— with the utmost seriousness.
Namor is a determined fighter, so even though
he is weakened by the drying device, he's
still able to use his spear to escape the
machine.
In an effort to maintain her fighting advantage,
Shuri commands her ship to fly to the desert,
slightly inland from the water.
As they touch down, Shuri dons her Black Panther
suit, and she and Namor begin to fight.
Meanwhile, in the ocean, the Wakandans are
preparing to retreat.
However, as they do, a group of Talokans approaches
their ship riding two humpback whales.
They throw a massive number of small bombs
at the ship, leading to panic and mass casualties.
Despite the destruction, the Wakandans abandon
their retreat, and the fighting between the
Wakandans and Talokans becomes more intense
than ever.
While the Wakandans' losses are no doubt terrible,
there is still some redemption to be had in
this battle.
Okoye takes on Attuma for the second time,
looking for redemption after he bested her
with ruthless precision during their earlier
fight in Boston.
Although her failure to save Shuri from being
taken by the Talokans in that confrontation
led to her dismissal from the Dora Milaje,
she comes back for her rematch wearing the
Midnight Angel suit Shuri created for her.
Whether it's the suit or simply her determination
to prove herself, Okoye manages to best Attuma
the second time around.
Elsewhere, Riri is taking on Namora for the
second time after the Talokan warrior knocked
her out on the bridge in Boston.
And just like Okoye, this time Riri is victorious.
Back in the desert, Shuri appears to have
the upper hand against a weakened Namor – that
is, until Namor recovers his spear and stabs
Shuri in the abdomen, stopping her in her
tracks.
Namor is somewhat solemn about his victory,
informing her that things could have been
different between them and their two nations.
Clearly, Namor is still of the opinion that
Wakanda and Talokan should work together to
take on the whole world, mutually protecting
both their countries and their vibranium.
"Are you an ally or an enemy?"
Unfortunately, Shuri is in no state to debate
Namor now, as she seems like she is very likely
to be dying from his attack.
As she stands there struggling, she flashes
back to her encounter with Killmonger on the
ancestral plane where he asked her if she
would be noble like T'Challa, or take care
of business like him.
This memory seems to give her the strength
she needs to jump back into action.
Her checkmate move is a massive explosion
that injures Namor badly while she remains
protected by her Black Panther suit.
Shuri then stands over Namor, apparently poised
to kill him.
Yet, as she looks down on him with her weapon
ready to deliver a fatal blow, she starts
to remember everything that she's been through
over the past year, including T'Challa's death,
the devastation of Wakanda by Talokan, and
her mother's death.
Finally, she sees her mother, who urges her
toward peace.
"Show them who you are."
Shuri stops her attack on Namor and tells
him that vengeance has consumed both of them
– but it must not consume their people.
Namor surrenders to her, and Shuri promises
to keep Talokan secret from the rest of the
world.
Shuri and Namor fly to the site of the battle
between their peoples and stop the fighting,
declaring Wakanda and Talokan to have a truce.
With the central conflict of the movie put
to rest, the characters start to return to
their normal lives.
In Wakanda, they replant the heart-shaped
herb that Shuri reconstructed.
Shuri sends Riri home without the Ironheart
suit she created for her, but she does not
leave empty-handed; Shuri has also fixed the
car Riri was working on in Boston, which Riri
explains belonged to her father.
Then, there is a gathering of all of Wakanda
that fans of the first "Black Panther" movie
will recognize as the ritual T'Challa participated
in to officially become Wakanda's ruler.
This time, the ceremony is meant for Shuri,
but when a ship flies in, and Shuri is introduced,
instead of the princess emerging, it's M'Baku
who appears.
As he jumps from the ship, he announces that
he wishes to challenge Shuri for the throne.
In the ocean, Namora confronts Namor about
surrendering to Wakanda — a move she is
none too pleased with — but Namor reassures
her that the surface world will once again
come for Wakanda and, when it does, Wakanda
will have no choice but to turn to them.
Apparently, Namor still believes the world
is eventually going to attack Wakanda for
its vibranium and he is prepared to bide his
time until that happens.
The truce may be shakier than it at first
appeared.
Meanwhile, in America, Okoye rescues Agent
Ross from CIA custody, gleefully declaring
she has never seen a colonizer in chains before.
Perhaps Okoye's actions were a bit of a thank
you after Ross was arrested for leaking secrets
to her and Shuri earlier in the film.
One way or another, it seems the alliance
between Ross and Wakanda is set to grow even
deeper than it already was.
Instead of the ceremony in Wakanda that she
was expected to attend, Shuri is instead found
in Haiti where Nakia now lives.
Right before the credits roll, Shuri goes
to the beach by herself and burns T'Challa's
funeral robes in a fire on the beach.
This is a ritual Ramonda tried to perform
with Shuri earlier in the movie, before they
were interrupted by Namor.
A mid-credits scene then picks back up on
the beach.
As Shuri sits in the sand looking out toward
the water, Nakia approaches her with a child
at her side named Toussaint.
Nakia introduces the child to his Aunt Shuri,
who realizes with surprise that she's meeting
T'Challa's son.
Nakia explains that T'Challa and Ramonda knew
about Toussaint, but beyond them, the child
was a secret.
When T'Challa learned he was dying, he prepared
his son and asked Nakia to keep him away from
the funeral.
While these were clearly acts of love, it
is hard not to wonder if keeping Toussaint
away from Wakanda was the right idea.
On the other hand, the child seems fairly
content when he tells Shuri that Toussaint
is his Haitian name, but his real name is
T'Challa Jr. — a revelation that indicates
that T'Challa and Nakia, despite moving him
so far away in secret, ultimately do want
to acknowledge that the child is the true
heir to Wakanda's throne.
What that could mean for leadership in Wakanda
isn't clear, though, because, after Shuri
and T'Challa Jr.'s brief exchange, the credits
continue, and "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever"
comes to an end with a promise that Black
Panther will return.